dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir this is going
to be a more in-depth episode of the
series photorealistic rendering means
that we create a 3d model of a scene on
a computer and we run a light simulation
program that shows how it would look
like in reality these programs simulate
rays of lights that connect the camera
to the light sources and the scene and
compute the flow of energy between them
if you have missed our earlier episode
on metropolis light transport and if
you're interested make sure to watch it
first I've put a link in the description
box this time let's go one step beyond
classical light transport algorithms and
talk about a gradient domain rendering
technique and how we can use it to
create photorealistic images quicker
first of all what is a gradient the
gradient is a mathematical concept let's
imagine an elevation map of a country
where there are many hills and many flat
regions and imagine that you are an
ambitious hill climber who is looking
for a challenge therefore you would
always like to go in the direction that
seems to be the highest elevation
increase the biggest rock that you can
climb nearby the gradient is a bunch of
arrows that always point in the
direction of the largest increase on the
map here with blue you can see the
elevation map with the mountains and
below it with red the gradient of this
elevation map this is where you should
be going if you are looking for a
challenge it is essentially a guidebook
for aspiring hill climbers one more
example with a heat map the bluer colors
denote colder the reddish colors show
the warmer regions if you are freezing
the gradients will show you where you
should go to warm up so if you have the
elevation map it is really easy to
create the gradients out of it but what
if we have it the other way around this
would mean that we only have the guide
book the red arrows and from that we
would like to guess what the blue
elevation map looks like it's like a
crossword puzzle only way cooler in
mathematics we call this procedure
solving the Poisson equation so let's
try to solve it by hand I look at the
middle where there are no arrows
pointing in this direction only once
that point out of here meaning that
there is an increase outwards therefore
this has to be a huge hole
if I look at the corners I don't see
very long arrows meaning that there is
no real change in these parts therefore
it must be a flat region so we can solve
this Poisson equation and recreate the
map from the guidebook to see what this
is good for let's jump right into the
gradient domain renderer
imagine that we have this simple scene
with a light source an object that
occludes the light source and the camera
looking down on this shadow edge
let's rip out this region and create a
close-up of it imagine that the light
regions are large Hills on the elevation
map and the shadow edge is the ground
level below those previous algorithms
were looking to shoot as many ways as
possible towards the brighter regions
but not this one the gradient domain
algorithm is looking for gradients
abrupt changes in the illumination if
you will you can see these white red
pairs
next to each other these are the places
where the algorithm concentrates if we
compute the difference between them we
get the gradients of our elevation map
in these regions the difference is zero
therefore we would have infinitely small
arrows and from the previous examples we
solve the Poisson equation to get the
blue map back from the red arrows the
small arrows mean that we have a
completely flat region so we can
recognize that we have a wide wall in
the background by just looking at a few
places we don't need to explore every
inch of it like previous algorithms do
and as you can see at the shadow edge
the algorithm is quite interested in
this change in our gradients there will
be a large red arrow pointing from the
white to the red dot because we are
going from the darkness to a light
region after solving the Poisson
equation we recognize that there should
be a huge jump here so in the end with
this technique we can often get a much
better idea of the illumination in the
scene than we did with previous methods
that just try to explore every single
inch of it the result is improved output
images with much less noise even though
the gradient domain renderer computed
much less race than the previous random
algorithm excellent piece of work Bravo
now that we understand what gradients
and poissons equation is let's play a
quick game together and try to learn
these mathematical concepts from the
internet like
undergrad student would do and before
you run away in terror this is not
supposed to be pleasant I'll try to make
a point after reading this in
mathematics the gradient is a
generalization of the usual concept of
derivative of a function in one
dimension to a function in several
dimensions if f of x1 to xn is a
differentiable scalar valued function of
standard Cartesian coordinates in
euclidean space its gradient is the
vector whose components are the nth
partial derivatives of F it is thus a
vector valued function now let's proceed
to parsall's equation in mathematics
Poisson equation is a partial
differential equation of elliptic type
with broad utility in electrostatics
mechanical engineering and theoretical
physics it is used for instance to
describe the potential energy field
caused by a given charge or mass density
distribution this piece of text is one
of the reasons why I've started two
minute papers I try to pull the curtains
and show that difficult mathematical and
scientific concepts often conceal very
simple and intuitive ideas that anyone
can understand and I am delighted to
have you by my side on this journey this
was anything but two minutes I
incorporated a bit more details for you
to have a deeper understanding of this
incredible work I hope you don't mind
let me know if you liked it in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time